[Música]
como uno
y
un gordo
útil
voy a contar mi sol cuando el psoe es
historia de jesús
de escritura de economía familiar 19
por el contrario
pero eso
vecinas
m
si los octubres
y recuerdo un día maravilloso
y dijo
se puede caminar trotar
un vehículo
nada más
isabel cuadrado
mira calidad y maravilloso nos acercamos
utilizamos preventa
sí sí
es decir
monseñor el accidente
yo conozco la piel dejaste el monoplaza
sobre esto
me encanta ese vehículo
también dos niños y un niño convulsión
volvió el brazo del conductor
y no se dio la fuga fue atender la
emergencia
esa persona su señor
[Música]
en el tiempo
he elegido vestir
ah
señor
o sí
ese ritmo se llama luis uno
y
y todos lo conocían
afrontar los roles
no tenemos nada
trabajo junto al vídeo
y
mi mente
hermano de sus cuatro hijas
la mayor viviente sur
sí
a mí sí
mi viejo mis primos mi hermana yo
mi hermano además de trillizas
de una sola noche
es un poco de secundaria
y es que las preguntas
y es para estudiar medicina no dejamos
opción
es una ciudad de euros
yo
así
sí
en cero
[Música]
de mi cabeza
pero tiene
no lo sé
esta sensibilidad
volví
muy bien
que no importa que los niños y este es
el camino
y salí a jugar
en una pierna
todo se enseña 6
eso
y nosotros
los dulces necesitan nutrirse
recuperarse así
ahora sí
un fácil
resuelves
pero comprende
necesito que inspiren al resucitó
cada uno mensual
muy difícilmente no
no
tuvieron un poco
lograr 90 sobre 45 desayunos de 2200
y es entendieron
que competir las acciones
todos todos
tenemos las niñas
una pregunta
de día alguien dijo alguna vez una
casita de dos aguas
gracias
alguna vez
terminales si ustedes cuando eran niños
dijeron
[Música]
a los ancianos
ciclo de agua
y si lo desea
i
porque eso no criticamos
yo soy orgulloso
esposado
de la nada
d
a él
bueno
por venir
y
[Música]
tu vida
para pedirle agradecer expresa jesús
millán ese niño
que quiere ser algo bueno por
dios
para las generaciones de riesgos para
nuestra generación y para la generación
[Música]
sí
con ciudad
y recuerdo
[Aplausos]
y